dr. bright stirred his coffee with a
spoon taking a long moment to savor the
aroma one unusual aspect of his bond
with 963 is that certain sensations were
different in each bonding he occupied
colors were slightly different smells
triggered different emotions and coffee
cheap instant coffee was unusually good
in this body who knew that a chimpanzees
tastebuds and instant coffee got along
so well
good morning old chap dr. Keynes nails
clacked on the tile floor as he trotted
into the break room got some good news
and some bad news first the good news
682 escaped again last night how the
hell's that good news well after killing
790 two guards on his way out he stole a
car and went on alcoholic bender across
two states
dr. bright furrowed his brow you're
pullin my leg if that's the good news
Kame barked happily I'm not done yet
6a to wrap the car around a tree at 150
miles per hour the airbag did not deploy
the big bad lizard is dead of course dr.
bright said drunk driving why didn't we
think of this sooner
well what's the bad news oh it was your
car
drunk driving destroys lives don't do it
okay brought to you by MA DD i-- t CW is
monkeys against drunk driving in their
car which you stole